hey 42 here the dark through a long time
we suspected it's up to no good only
existing to provide a hiding place for
goblins vampires and random pieces of
Lego but it turns out that pretty much
the entire universe is made up of stuff
that we cannot see cannot interact with
and have no idea what the bloody hell it
is in fact things we can't see
only make up a pathetic five percent of
existence so if you think your room
looks messy now wait till you see the
other ninety five percent yet we stumble
through life like drunk death mold
barely taking in a fraction of
everything around and somehow still
managed to come up with space travel
cancer treatments frozen yogurt so what
is the huge amount of of a storm where
did it come from can I poke it and will
it care if I do
does the dark matter the problem with
the universe is that it's getting to
fund and we need to find a way to
account for this once we had realized
that the universe was expanding we came
up with two possible outcomes firstly
that the density of matter and energy
would eventually halt the continuous
expansion initiated by the Big Bang and
then the universe would collapse
disappearing back into a Big Crunch
singularity or returning down the back
of the sofa depending on what you
believe the second option was that it
will keep expanding forever
what the expansion would slow down by
smaller and smaller increments the
trouble was that when we pointed the
Hubble telescope at distant supernovae
not only did we catch them in the shower
but we realize that in the past the
universe expanded slower than it did now
that means that not only is gravity not
slowing our expansion
something must be speeding it or we
named this something dark energy dark
energy makes up 70% of the universe and
Dark Matter makes them 25% but these two
things despite their name didn't appear
as part of the same concept they're not
the same thing we
needed each one to account for different
phenomena for dark energy it was a
swelling belly of the universe but dark
matter was needed to explain the
unusually large mass of galaxies
yacouba's captain jan walked after
following the Ministry of unusual names
became astronomer and theorized the idea
of dark matter but it was Swiss
astrophysicist Fritz Zwicky who also
after leaving the Ministry of unusual
names made the first formal theory about
its existence in 1933 the wiki was
looking at a distant cluster of galaxies
and worked out that the motion of the
galaxies at the edge of the cluster was
much faster than it mathematically
should be where is all this extra
gravitational pull coming from there
must be a huge mass that we aren't able
to observe so the idea of dark matter
was born matter which has mass therefore
gravity was almost no other interaction
with baryonic matter which is what
physicists call normal matter because
they just have to come up with a funky
name for everything all right so there
is a huge amount of stop hiding in the
cupboards or more accurately we're stuck
in a tiny cupboard and we have no idea
what's in the rest of the house so do we
know anything at all about dark matter
well yeah we do we know that it's primal
meaning it came from the Big Bang since
there's no realistic way for it to be
continuously created all right that's a
start
but then if it was all from the Big Bang
gun it still exists now then it must
also be stable otherwise it would have
changed into something else by now so we
assume that dark matter can serve
something called parity meaning that it
can't decay into ordinary matter the
simplest theory is that all dark matter
is of just one time called a wimp weakly
interacting massive pop so they're very
very heavy but they're also extremely
anti-social rarely interacting with
their own kind let alone with baryonic
matter but try as we might yet
to see a particle dark matter but who
wants a world full of wimps Bogdan da
Brasco Don Ling have discussed the idea
of complex dark matter these are dark
particles that interact with themselves
in the same way that ordinary Matadors
so it sounds like dark matter could just
be a mirror a baryonic matter with all
the same rules and regulations but we
know that this can't be exactly true the
similarities must end at some point
because we see that there must given by
dark matter around galaxies is spread
out in a sphere rather than a flattened
disc that are galaxies but just like
normal a dark matter could have hot and
cold particles baryonic are cold
particles but we also have hot matter
better known as neutrinos these move
close to light speed and have almost
zero maths dark matter could have a
similar spread with hot and dark
particles which sounds like an erotic
side pipe film the cold dark particles
will be the wimps that we discussed
earlier the question is are we ever
going to find any evidence for dark
matter or just like Ben Affleck's acting
debility is it going to remain entirely
theoretical there are a number of
different experiments currently going on
so we're just hoping to observe that
incredibly rare interaction between
baryonic dark matter by creating an
extremely insulated space where very
little of the regular rays waves and
particles are usually pass through stuff
creating all that noise and making it
difficult to see if any dark
interactions are happening I've got one
such example is a large underground
xenon experiment that I have talked
about in a previous video you can find a
link to that in the description another
way maybe to use our old friends the
Large Hadron Collider we won't be able
to observe it directly in a detective
itself but in these powerful collisions
it's possible we could find some energy
that's missing perhaps showing the dark
emissions how occurred accounting for
this lost and it
of course if you really want baryonic
matter and dark matter to interact you
need to mix dark room and light room and
put on some Bob Marley it works at house
parties at least and when it comes to
finding dark energy
well that's equally problematic as dark
matter and we can probably only observe
its effects on a much grander galactic
scale the Hobby everly telescope in
Texas is hoping to build a 3d map of the
early universe and so see more clearly
what dark Energy's role was in the
development of the universe so who knows
how much influence this dark energy and
dark matter will prove to have on the
world around perhaps ghosts are just
dark matter teenagers angrily slamming
doors in the opposite poles right next
to ours and hopefully the rapid
expansion of dark energy was the reason
I had to buy a new Belmonte it certainly
wasn't all sausage rolls thanks for the
view subscribe for more 42 the humble
caterpillar is one of the most mined
shatteringly incredulous creatures on
planet earth some photos can tell rich
detailed stories others inspire a
thousand questions